Annie Leibowitz one of the best
photographers in the world provides us
with new pictures from the set of Star
Wars 9 these pictures were released on
Wednesday in Vanity Fair and also
reveals some small plot details among
others Rey and kylo Ren can be seen who
are dramatically staged in a storm
another picture shows Finn and Jenna
riding a horse like creature called
orbeck another one confirms that the
Knights of Ren returned in the ninth
part after their small appearance in
star wars 7 we are definitely looking
forward to more material from the set
Star Wars 9 the rise of Skywalker will
be released on December 20th 2019 the
sequel of the minions solo film
officially got a name a few days ago the
secret to the mega successful for
minions released in 2015 will be called
minions the rise of GRU clever fans will
of course make a connection to the Star
Wars the rise of Skywalker which will be
released at the end of the year the only
difference is that the minions movie
probably deals with the rise of the
Willing crew who became the leader of
the minions in the first part the
minions and drew had their first
appearance in Despicable Me from 2010
since then
the film has ranked on the sensational
19th place of the most successful films
of all time minions the rise of GRU will
be released on the 3rd of July 2020 the
last episode of The Game of Thrones saga
was released last week so one of the
biggest and most popular series of all
time is finished forever but that
doesn't mean that it will be quiet now
around the Song of Ice and Fire on the
one hand a documentary on HBO will be
released today which takes a look behind
the scenes of the 8th season in addition
there are also various spin-offs and
follow up series in progress
according to a blog post by george RR
martin there are currently 3 of them
with the long night currently the most
advanced this one will be about a story
that takes place in the Age of Heroes
about 8,000 years before the main game
of Thrones plot nothing is yet known
about the other to follow up series last
but not least there are the last two
books for Martin Song of Ice and Fire
namely the winds of winter and at
of spring many fans who were
disappointed by the eighth season might
find their long-awaited incoherent end
of the saga when the books are released
so far not much has been known about
Christopher Nolan's new movie Tennant
only the three actress Robert Pattinson
John David Washington and Elizabeth
ibiki are confirmed
now something more has been leaked
Tennant is supposed to become an
action-packed espionage epic
in addition filming will take place
around the globe in a total of seven
countries Michael crane who is one of
the regular actors in Nolan's films will
also be part of the film again more
information will certainly come to light
bit by bit in the near future the
release date for Christopher Nolan's
Tennant is July 2020 almost two weeks
ago Daniel Craig injured himself so
badly during the shooting of 125 that he
had to be flown to a hospital in the USA
meanwhile the shooting has of course
been completely put on hold and many
fans even fear of the late release of
125 but that's probably not the case
because on Wednesday the official bombed
Twitter channel said that Craig had to
undergo an ankle operation after he fell
unhappily during a script at the same
time the fans are reassured and it's
announced that Craig's injury will not
significantly influence the release date
in April 2020 so Bunn fans can first
breathe a sigh of relief and then
presumably see the cinema spectacle with
Ralph Fiennes Naomi Harris and many more
in the cinemas on April 9 2020 the real
film version of the Tom and Jerry
cartoon becomes more and more concrete
in so admin actor Michael Pena aka Lewis
was engaged for the cast a few days ago
after Chloe grace Moretz he is to play
the role of the villain an opponent to
Tom & Jerry he will appear in the form
of the assistant hotel manager Terrence
who not only harasses his employee Kayla
led by Moretz but also wants to
eliminate Jerry and later also Tom so it
is time to stick together and let Caleb
Tom and Jerry defeat Terrence for behind
the camera Tim story was hired who also
directed fantastic for the u.s. American
release date of the Tom and Jerry movie
is April 16th 2021
Constantin film has now secured the
rights to a Just Cause video game
filming that has been in the pipeline
for many years according to the rap
magazine Just Cause film will become a
global franchise and production will
start as early as next year there is
also good news for all fans who are
already rolling their eyes at the world
video game filming John wick and mentor
Derek hold steady also wrote the scripts
for the first two John wick movies will
also write the script for the Just Cause
movie the Just Cause series has always
been known for its exaggerated action
and unique humor that focuses on the
secret agent Rico Rodriguez who causes
unrest and invented States and
overthrows the red Jim's there with
everything he has to offer what exactly
the film version will be about will
surely be reiatsu
[Music]